[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon is based on
the georgia or martin's targaryen
history book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
but back to aegon's conquest king
torrence stark also known as the king
who kneeled
was a head of house stark who reigned as
king in the north
when aegon the first targaryen invaded
westeros with his dragons then started
the war of conquest
unlike every other king in westeros the
king in the north refused to fight aegon
but instead kneeled before him
prioritizing his people over his ego
he was the last king in the north until
the secession of the north and the
riverlands in the war of the five kings
and the coronation of robb stark how
stark ruled as kings in the north
stretching back into the mists of time
before written history began six
thousand years ago
when the andals invaded all of southern
westeros
when the andals arrived the stark kings
in the north were already ruling at
winterfell
according to legend the first king in
the north was brandon stark
better known as brando builder who lived
eight thousand years ago
according to legends he led the forces
of the north in the war for the dawn
against the white walkers and built the
wall to guard against their return
and also began construction of vineefeld
the kings in the north were successfully
able to fend off the andals from
invading
holding the line of the neck at the
choke point of mode kalin
as a result the north remained the only
independent kingdom of the first men
the north would be independent kingdom
until aegon the conqueror comes with his
sisters and their dragons
and the unfortunate stark king who would
rule the north at this time happened to
be torrence stark
let's tell the tale of the king who
kneeled after the riverlands and storm's
end had fallen under the control of
aegon to conquer
torrance stark called his banners he was
aware that due to the vast distance of
the north
it would take a long time to assemble
his army after the field of fire
which was the pivotal battle that
decided the result of the war of
conquest in which kings mirned gardner
of the reach
and lorne lannister of the rock faced
the invading egg on the conqueror
on the open field the two kings combined
the armies of both the richest kingdom
and the most populous kingdom terming it
the iron fist
their total force numbered 60 thousand
men
in contrast aegon's army was outnumbered
by five to one
the battle was fought on a wide field in
the reach however aegon the conqueror
unleashed his three dragons against the
enemy army
four thousand men burned alive that day
including
king mirn himself king lauren instead
bend the knee
to the targaryen warlord he was
disappointed lord paramount of the
westerlands and warden of the west
with the death of king myrn house
gardener which had ruled the reach since
the time of the first
man became extinct house tyrell the
hereditary stewards of the gardeners
then surrendered highgarden to aegon in
return aegon raised harlen tyrell the
head of the family
to lord paramount of the reach and
warden of the south
while at highgarden aegon the first
learned that tauren had crossed the neck
and entered the riverlands leading an
army of 30 thousand men
tauren amassed his army and marched to
meet the targaryen warlord
aegon the first abandoned his plans to
march south
and that once started his way north
racing ahead of his army on valerian
both rhaenys and is dania targaryen as
well as all the lords who had bent
the knee to aegon after harrenhal and
the field of fire
verse sent the word of this movement
savanturn reached the banks of the
trident
he found a host of 45 000 men and three
dragons waiting for him
after seeing aegon's dragons and his
massive host
doran realized the war was already lost
even without dragon storm stark and his
northerners were outnumbered
but there was no doubt he would give a
good fight against those odds
but when he saw three dragons a fake on
the conqueror
he spent the entire night with his
generals thinking of what is next and
perhaps his final move as the king in
the north should be
touring scouts had reported seeing the
ruins of harehole
and tauren had heard the counts of the
field of fire as well
some of his lords urged him to attack
but he realized that a similar fate
would evade him
if he tried to force a crossing others
of his lords urged the king of the north
to fall back to mount kailin
to make his stand there tauren's bastard
half brother brandon snow
offered to cross the trident the dark to
kill the dragons
at the end tauren did send his
half-brother brain and snow to aegon's
camp
but not to kill aegon's dragons but to
treat with aegon
the whole night messages went back and
forth and the next morning tauren
crossed the trident
where he kneeled and laid his crown at
the feet of fagon the first targaryen
and saw her filthy in exchange for his
life and the lives of the northmen
torrance stark sore filthy to house
targaryen
instead of fighting he chose to bend the
knee and surrendered his crown in return
for torrance submission aegon allowed
house stark to continue ruling the north
as they had for thousands of years
but as vessels of the iron throne they
held the titles of lord paramount of the
north lord the winner fell and warden of
the north
the starks thus retain their ancient
positions and traditions
ever since thorin is known as the king
who kneeled
it's unknown what aegon did with
torrance crown
the inn of the kneeling man later arose
where thorin had bent at the knee
after torrents surrendered the company
of the rose a sell sword company was
formed
by men and according to some accounts
women from the north
who refused to bend the knee to egon the
first targaryen
these men and women willingly chose
exile across the narrow sea
tauren's sons did not agree with the
targaryen rule
some of them spoke of rebelling and
raising the stark banner
veteran gave his consent or not his
no rebellions by how stark are known
thus far lord torren's daughter was
married to ronald loren
lord of theory this marriage had been
arranged by queen reigning targaryen
as an attempt to knit the new realm
together their letters at the cereal
which suggests
that lord stark only agreed to this
match after much protest
and that his sons had refused to attend
the wedding lord ronald would be killed
early in the reign of king genius the
first targaryen by his own brother jonas
it's unknown whether thorin's daughter
was still alive at this point
tauren was entombed in the crypts of
ennerfel after his death
three centuries later turin's descendant
ned stark was amongst the rebel lords
against aegon the conqueror's descendant
aerys the mad king during robert's
rebellion
in which the targaryen dynasty was
deposed and robert crowned as the new
king
although some northerners neared thorin
as the king who kneeled
his ascendants the starks argued that
thorne saved thousands of lives that day
and that his critics forget that they
are alive today because of him
king tauren is mentioned a few times in
game of thrones for kneeling down to
aegon and his dragons
the most significant mention of the king
who kneeled was in season seven
when jon snow appears before daenerys
targaryen on dragonstone
the latter scoffs and sir davos sievert
presents jon as the king in the north
and declares that the last person who
held that title was torren stark
who banned the need to her ancestor
aegon the conqueror
using tauren's declaration of loyalty in
perpetuity to try and persuade jon into
confirming the nords filthy to house
targaryen
and abandoning the king in the north
title king in the north feminine
equivalent being queen in the north
is a title given to the ruler of the
north during its time as an
independent kingdom before and after the
coming of the targaryens
the title also used for the rulers of
the north was kings of winter
during the opening stages of the war of
the five kings
lord robb stark was proclaimed as the
new king in the north by his bannerman
the first in 300 years after torrance
stark
the kingdom of the north came to a
temporary end after the red wedding when
ruse bolton
who conspired with house frey and house
lannister initiated a massacre of the
northern army
and personally stabbed rob stark through
the heart however
the kingdom of the north was
re-established after a short few years
under the bolton rule
when the starks led by jon snow and
since the stark later gathered an army
of northern houses
still loyal to house stark the free folk
and the knights of the vale
and retook winterfell from the boltons
with the boltons defeated
jon snow was proclaimed the new king in
the north reasserting the north's
independence from the iron throne
the kingdom of the north came to a
temporary end once again
when jon bent the need to queen the
natives targaryen in order to gain her
full support in the great war
like torrent stark jon snow banned the
need to save his people
after the death of daenerys targaryen
sansa stark declared independence from
the armed round
and herself the queen in the north and
thus the kingdom in the north was
reestablished once again
her brother brain stark became the ruler
of the six kingdoms
three hundred years after torin stark
niggled to aegon targaryen
now aegon's descendant jon snow whose
real name is aegon
kneel down to tauren's descendant brain
all of this is part of the targaryen
history
and the upcoming game of thrones prequel
house of the dragon is based on the
targaryen history
we are bound for an epic journey
starting in 2022 which is when the first
episode of the game of thrones pretty
cool airs
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace